as aggravating as it can be when a
trailer spoils a movie it's worse when a
poster does it their designers only have
one job to create a single compelling
picture that gets audiences excited to
see a film but it doesn't always work
out here are some posters that somehow
managed to spoil the entire movie Kiefer
Alert 2003's phone booth is the story of
a man played by Colin Farrell who stands
inside a phone booth for the better part
of a day and for almost the entire film
surprising as it may sound that premise
leads to a pretty interesting story
because he's a hostage who's being told
to stay inside or else by a voice on the
other end of the line that's the movies
central mystery who's the caller with
all this hype surrounding the mystery
man it'd be pretty silly if the
promotional material revealed his
identity and yet that's exactly what
happened
Kiefer Sutherland is featured
prominently in one version of phone
booths poster as well as the DVD case
looking very suspicious if you saw the
poster before you saw the flick the
experience of watching phone booth is
reduced to waiting around for Sutherland
to finally show up as the villain at the
very end as promised isn't it funny
you hear a phone ring and it could be
anybody
Ender's ending this particular Enders
game poster spoils the finale of the
film by showing the climaxes most
important shot coupled with even a basic
synopsis of the film this gives it all
away 2013's
Ender's Game is the story of a kid named
ender who must train to prevent an alien
invasion couple that knowledge with the
posters image of Endor blowing up a
planet with a giant pair of mega lasers
and there really aren't a lot of
questions left on the table we destroy
the planet we destroy the queens and
even if one doesn't immediately connect
the dots before starting the film the
posters true nature will eventually
reveal itself instill guarantee that the
ending is spoiled way ahead of time fun
terminated while the second trailer for
2015's Terminator Genisys gave away this
big spoiler as well trailers are far
easier to avoid than poster which
reveals its contents the second you see
it the designers of this Terminator
Genisys poster chose to reveal that its
hero John Connor is actually a
terminator and by extension the villain
a twist that doesn't creep up until
halfway through the movie worse yet this
is the movies only real twist it's not
like the marketing team had anything
else up their sleeves when they revealed
this bombshell this is the movie's sole
hook leading some to speculate that the
poster was just a desperate attempt to
garner excitement for the film even at
the risk of cannibalizing its only
threat of entry throwing the fight
1985's rocky for allegorically speaks to
Cold War tensions between the United
States and Soviet Union world champion
Rocky Balboa represents the US while the
unfeeling Ivan Drago represents the
Russians
it's about as clear-cut as a movie can
get in terms of setting up an obvious
good guy and bad guy given that dynamic
no one should have any questions about
who is going to win the big fight at the
end however in case there is any
lingering doubt in a prospective viewers
mind rocky did lose at the end of the
first film after all this poster cleared
that confusion right up featuring the
title character cheering bruised and
draped in an American flag the poster
puts the film's Indian front and center
for all to see no twist in Thailand for
the most part the marketing for 2016 10
Cloverfield Lane was very carefully
crafted to maintain
we sense of mystery audiences were left
to wonder why John Goodman was so intent
on keeping Mary Elizabeth Winstead
trapped in his bunker did it have
something to do with the Cloverfield
monster from the last movie with
Cloverfield in the title
no one knew at least until an official
poster came out in Thailand and
blatantly spoiled the big finale it
depicts an alien spacecraft with
Winstead booking it away from the ship
in a run for her life
this poster spoiled the massive twist at
the end of the movie as well as the rest
of the story leading up to that point
all with a single image thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]
[Applause]
you